un nouveau visage pour la gare de La
Verrière démarrée en février 2022 les
travaux d'aménagement du nouveau pôle
multilodal sont en cours objectif
fluidifier les transports en commun et
la circulation automobile dans ce
secteur traversé chaque jour par 25000
voyageurs c'est une demande globale
d'amélioration et effectivement
d'améliorer globalement le
fonctionnement des transports et
moderniser effectivement ce secteur qui
en avait bien besoin d'où aujourd'hui
cette mise en service de la gare
routière une gare routière toute neuve
qui représente plus de 850 mouvements
par jour
desservis par 11 lignes cet écostation
de bus permet un meilleur accueil des
usagers par rapport à l'ancienne gare
routière en complément un nouveau parvis
piétonnier de 6000 m² verra le jour en
septembre 2023 le passage souterrain
sera prochainement rénové avec de
nouveaux éclairages pour plus de
sécurité au total 11,5 millions d'euros
seront nécessaires à ces réaménagement
vraiment d'être fait parce que c'est une
gamme garde vraiment desservie c'est un
vieux il fallait renouveler et voilà
quoi tout ça dans un cadre paysager très
qualitatif puisqu'on plante plus de 165
arbres mais également plus de 23000
plantes couvrent seuls et graminées en
parallèle à nouveau parking relais de
900 places sera créé c'était difficile
sera 100% autonome en énergie grâce à
des panneaux photovoltaïques sa
livraison est prévue en mars 2023 pour
un coup de plus de 10 millions d'euros
les usagers qui auront des des passes
Navigo notamment annuels auront accès à
ce parking relais dans des conditions
préférentielles pour finalement un
stationnement beaucoup plus
adapté et beaucoup plus confortable les
chefs vont des travaux du pôle gare Nord
est prévu pour fin 2023 première étape
avant le démarrage du projet urbain
garbecane qui verra la construction de
1500 logements et 60000 mètres carrés de
pôle d'activités économiques